what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for animal roar and today I will be
breaking down the many many developments
in the most recent chapter of the attack
on Titan story a ton of important pieces
are lining up for the final showdown and
it seems that the one and only Levi has
come up with a master plan a plan that
may pit him directly against Aaron
himself a massive new Alliance has just
been formed an alliance that includes
five different Titan shifters and two
overpowered Ackerman's and their targets
appear to be the Jaeger ist's Zeek
Jaeger and eventually Aaron's Godzilla
Titan there is so much to talk about so
let's get into it if you enjoyed the
attack on titan content right here on
the channel and you want us to keep it
going please leave a like it really does
help and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar please don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications if you
don't turn on all notifications you're
gonna miss a lot of our videos
it's just how YouTube works a big thank
you to all of our anime upper patrons
who make videos like this one possible
I'll talk more about patreon at the end
of the video but first please be advised
that this video will contain attack on
Titan manga spoilers we are dealing with
the latest developments in the story we
are way beyond the anime is so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned chapter 1 to 6 starts off as a
flashback in which we see just how hanji
and Levi managed to evade capture
hanji hit Levi in the forest while
treating his wounds and she also fought
off any members of the military who got
close enough to finding them this
includes outright shooting the soldiers
who were pursuing them even though I'm
sure it broke on geez hard to do it it
seems ironic that hanji was forced to
literally kill other members of the
scouts in order to avoid being captured
by the Jaeger ists but this just shows
how much the story has changed over
these past few arcs alliances keep
shifting friends become enemies enemies
become allies it's just how attack on
Titan work
hanji is doing her best to treat Levi's
wounds with the limited resources that
she has at her disposal but thankfully
she is a scientific genius so she's able
to carefully stitch Levi's wounds and
take care of him as efficiently as
possible under the circumstances hanji
believes that Levi's survived the
explosion for the same reason that he
was the only one who didn't turn into a
Titan his unique Ackerman bloodline
makes his body fundamentally different
from the other aliens and this allows
him to overcome injuries that would have
killed a normal person as Levi lies
unconscious hanji is contemplating what
they should do next
she even considers just staying in the
woods and hiding out there for the long
term because the way that things stand
now they are either going to end up in a
jail cell or worse regardless of whether
Zeek succeeds with his plan or whether
Aaron ends up betraying Zeke and taking
power for himself the Jaeger ist's can
still use Zeke strategically-placed
spinal fluid to control the island for
the foreseeable future
but then as hanji is making a cart so
she can move Levi's around she receives
a telepathic communication from Aaron
the same communication that all the
other aliens received in fact just like
Myka saw Levi also receives the message
and he regains consciousness immediately
after Aaron's communication ends Levi
says that he screwed up he didn't
realize that Zeke was prepared to die
and as a result he didn't take all the
necessary precautions during his fight
with Zeke
Levi tells hanji that they cannot just
hide away and stay out of the conflict
Levi is determined to kill Zeke once and
for all and he will stop at nothing in
order to make that happen back in the
present time we see that Levi is fully
conscious again and he is speaking to
Magath and Peake McGrath is fully aware
of Levi's incredible strength and he
considers just shooting Levi now while
he is vulnerable but Levi tells him that
he can either shoot him or actually
listen to what he has to say
McGrath says that he'll listen first
before he shoots
hanji that explains that Zeke wants to
use Eren in order to harness the power
of the founding titan without being
affected by king Fritz's ideology hanji
makes it clear that the founding titan
is incredibly large and seemingly
impossible
to conquer so their only option now is
to join forces this is a pretty insane
proposition
Levi Ackerman and Han Jie people who
sacrificed so much for the scouts and
for defending the island are actually
considering teaming up with Marlin
invaders however Aaron's Godzilla Titan
is an absolute juggernaut so if they
really do plan to somehow stop Aaron
they will have to use all the assets at
their disposal not even Levi the living
legend himself can take the new Aaron on
his own and that's saying a lot
elsewhere on the island corny is still
having an internal debate about his
intention to feed falco to his mother's
Titan corny is thinking about the best
way to get this boy into his mom's mouth
yes I just said that sentence thank you
attack on Titan II and he doesn't know
whether he should just use brute force
or some other means if he uses force
Falco might transform into the jaw Titan
so Coney decides to try a pretty
hilarious tactic Coney leads Falco to
his mom's Titan in raga ecovillage and
he casually asks Falco to help him brush
the Titans teeth definitely not
suspicious at all like what anyway corny
seriously tries to tell Falco to climb a
beam above the Titans mouth and start
brushing it's pearly whites but before a
confused Falco can actually do it Gabi
and Armin arrive on horseback
Gabi screams at Falco not to do what
Kony says because Falco inherited the JA
titan and Kony is trying to feed him to
his mother in order to save her Falco is
confused because he still doesn't
remember becoming the JA titan and
before Falco can react Coney brings his
blade to Falco's throat and warns the
others to stay back as Coney drags Falco
up the wooden ladder in an attempt to
get him close to the mouth of the Titan
Armin decides to save Falco by
sacrificing himself Armin prepares to
enter Kony's mother's mouth instead of
Falco again a sentence I never thought
I'd say but Coney can't bear to see that
happen so corny leaves Falco and leaps
into the air knocking Armin out of the
it's path and saving him from being
eaten when they are all safely on the
ground
Armand asks Connie why he didn't just
let him die this would have saved his
mom since she would have just inherited
the colossal Titan instead of the jaw
Titan but Connie couldn't let that
happen
his mother wanted him to become a
soldier that she could be proud of and
killing a kid or letting a close friend
sacrifice himself in order to save her
is not something that she would have
wanted instead of trying to feed someone
to his mother
Connie tells Arman that they should go
be the kind of soldiers that his mother
would be proud of this whole series of
events seems pretty crazy to me Arman
seems to be just filled with
self-loathing and he nearly sacrificed
his own life for Connie's mom imagine
sacrificing a commander of Erin's
caliber just so Arman could one day
decide to use the colossal Tynes power
to save Connie's mom a regular civilian
with no military training that's some
brilliant strategizing there Arman
but as ridiculous and unstable as Arman
state of mind appears to be this bizarre
event did accomplish one thing after
they just saw armed and attempting to
sacrifice his own life to save Falco I
think it's safe to assume that gabby and
falco will now trust armin they now know
without a shadow of a doubt that Arman
doesn't mean them harm and that they can
trust him going forward the next scene
takes us to a hospital where we finally
learned the answer to attack on Titan
single biggest mystery what happened to
make us a scarf it turns out that the
scarf was taken by Louise that girl
Mikasa saved back in tras district after
Micah's has saved her Louise became a
huge Mikasa Stan and she eventually
joined the Jaeger ists apparently Louise
is dying due to a thunder spear wound to
the stomach but she managed to preserve
Micah's a scarf after Aaron told her to
just throw the scarf away this was back
when Aaron was in his emote under a
stage and he was trying to push Armin
and Mikasa as far away from him as
possible Louise tells Micah's about how
much she idolizes and admires her but
Micah's I just grabbed a scarf and walks
away you have to give it to me cos I in
this scene she was pretty damn cold to
Louise however we have to remember that
Mikasa wasn't ever
on board with the Jaeger ist's and
Mikasa feels betrayed by all of these
people who were supposedly her friends
and comrades but ended up scheming
behind her back
Mika still wants the scarf though we all
know that because I can't really stay
mad at Aran as the last of the wall
Titans finally depart the capital the
whole eld an emperor flock rallies the
Jaeger ists while Jean stands quietly at
his side Mika says also there in the
crowd but when some guy asks her to join
da giris she says that she's not
interested dude because I was like the
first Jaeger Asst although I guess she's
more of an era NIST but either way the
action quickly jumps to some sort of
outdoor market or restaurant type thing
and we see the people they are
celebrating and praising the Jaeger ESCs
Armin Coney Gaby and Falco are on their
way to find Reiner but they decide to
sit down and eat as they're eating Coney
casually asks Armand whether a knee
might really be back and then what do
you know anni is literally right there
sitting down at the same table as they
are and gobbling up a pie I have to say
this was pretty damn funny although it
seemed kind of uncharacteristic for
attack on Titan I would expect a random
comical coincidence like this and like
the seven deadly sins or black clover
but not an attack on tight I was
expecting the reunion between Annie and
Armin after all those years to be more
epic than this random scene where they
meet each other by accident while Annie
is stuffing her face with a pie but what
can you do as hitch returns to the table
where she had left a neat wait for her
she sees a note in which Annie explains
that she decided to leave with Armin and
kony I kind of feel bad for hitch here
hitch got ditched although this is
definitely better for hitch in the long
run if she had been caught helping Annie
the Jaeger ists would have executed her
for treason so by leaving her at this
time and he might have actually saved
his life elsewhere in the capital the
gentle and benevolent King Emperor LDF
locked the great is preparing to execute
Jelena and a young con pawn John stands
beside him with a gun in his hand
presumably Jean is there to help with
the execution but I won't lie while I
was reading this part of the chapter I
was honest expecting for Jean to just
turn the gun on flock and shoot him
instead I guess I can understand flogs
desire to eggs
Jelena she had plotted with Zeke to
sterilize all LD ins but on cornpone
didn't do any of that all he did was
tried to help his own country along with
helping the ldiots flock wants to
execute a aankhon plan solely because
this guy doesn't want to give up on his
own country and just become a servant of
LDI instead this shows just how
ridiculous flock is no sane person would
expect to be on corn pone or anyone else
to just calmly accept the destruction of
his own nation after he had dedicated
his own life to try to save his people I
gotta say that I have huge respect for a
young component how he acted in this
scene floc offered to spare him if he
declared his undying loyalty to aldea
battalion [ __ ] pond refused he will not
Bend the need to people who want to
destroy the entire world including his
own homeland and he would rather die
than flatter the likes of flock we on
Capone is definitely a noble and
admirable man and someone who is willing
to stick with his principles even in the
face of certain death Jean then goes to
shoot or unconfirmed but he apparently
misses clearly he missed on purpose and
then in the next moment a young [ __ ]
Pony Alana and Jean are all consumed by
the cart tighten the cart tighten
appears out of nowhere swallows the
three of them and then disappears again
as fast as it appeared flock wonders
where Mikasa is because he wants her to
stop the car Titan but Mikasa is nowhere
to be found in reality Mikasa has
already met up with Coney Armin Annie
and the others and together they are all
making their way out of the capital
using two separate cards as they depart
Annie notices that someone appears to be
watching them from a window and we see a
silhouette to what looks like a
middle-aged man this is an interesting
little detail the only person I could
think of this being is maybe Keith
shadows but you really can't tell based
on the silhouette alone we know that
shadows is not a fan of the Jaeger issed
so it is possible that he will play some
role in toppling the Jaeger ist's
eventually the car titan brings our
young companion and jean outside the
city where they rendezvous with Magath
hanji and Levi Jean reveals that he
could no longer go along with the
craziness of flock and he made a deal
with Levi and McGrath to betray the
Jaeger ist's in the final scene Armin
Annie and the crew locate Reiner and
force him to wake up Reiner is shocked
to see any again and he doesn't know
what's going on but Kony tells him to
calm down there is no time to lose
because they are going to save the world
Levi Reiner Annie Armand Mikasa hanji
pique Falco Gabby Connie and John
appeared to now be all on the same side
and they all appear to be preparing to
take on the Jaeger ists back when Aaron
first transformed into his new massive
Godzilla Titan form it seemed as if
nothing would be able to stop him
however we now have the cart Titan the
female Titan the colossal Titan the jaw
Titan and the armored Titan all on the
same team and we have Levi and Mikasa on
that same team as well so is it possible
that all of them together could come up
with some strategy to actually defeat
the gigantic Eren they have brilliant
strategists and tactician like han ji
and Armin on their side but what could
they possibly do to stop Godzilla and
millions of colossal Titans I think that
this unlike the Alliance will have no
problem overthrowing flock and the
Jaeger ist's if that is their intention
but taking on the Jaeger ist's and
stopping Aaron from destroying the world
are two completely different things
in the end they will all depend on how
much control Aaron actually has over the
wall Titans and other Titans in general
if Aaron has fully harnessed the power
of Emir fritz and he can control the
Titans at will then I don't see how even
this powerful alliance could defeat
Aaron in his current form but if for
some reason Aaron's control of the other
Titans is not as complete as we have
been led to believe then it might be
possible for the Rebel Alliance to come
up with a strategy for tag-teaming Eren
alternatively this could all be just a
prelude to a Code Geass type ending
where Aaron plays the role of Lelouch a
main character who becomes such a
villain that he succeeds in unifying the
entire world against him now that we're
actually seeing the marlins a lying with
Armin Mikasa hanji and Levi the idea
that Aaron could be the Titan version of
the louche has become a bit more likely
he is already uniting the world against
him in a way that would have been
impossible before he decided to become a
quote/unquote
so maybe the Lelouch scenario is exactly
what Issei Amma is going for personally
I hope that the attack on Titan ending
won't follow the Code Geass ending too
closely because I want to say I want to
do something new and surprising but
we'll have to wait and see what do you
guys think about this unholy alliance
between the Marlin invaders and lifelong
survey corps members can this alliance
last and can they do anything against
Aaron even with five Titan shifters and
two Ackerman's or is Aaron just to Opie
please give me your thoughts down in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see more attack on Titan
content on the channel please leave a
like to let me know and if you happen to
be new to anime uproar please don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of clicking the bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you want to get our videos
otherwise YouTube will bury them it's
just the way it goes you can also hit me
up on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar for all the latest attack on
Titan news and updates I want to give a
big thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for making these videos possible
with all the problems constantly facing
YouTube patrons are more important than
ever thank you guys so much
first up let me think are the one tier
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including ingrid ah
Alan Adam the world Steelers the school
bus Tyson query no and a quiet respect
and of course I can't forget our pro
hero tier patrons including the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson Kings eldred's very dolla beat
Anatoli Cassatt's ki alpha do on hell
Cruz team Sparky 65 cricket XP Rohan
Kapoor Jessica Maloney Emperor otaku
Timothy Vargas Shawn dart Joe Stanton
jccc waka and John bunted if you enjoy
our videos and you feel that they
provide value for you consider becoming
a patron even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these legendary be
bold as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until
next time see us space cowboys
[Music]